hi this is presh holiker let's derive  the area of a circle intuitively  we'll start out by drawing a circle  which will subdivide with 16 wedges  we'll rearrange the wedges into a shape  that's more familiar to us  specifically we'll rearrange them into a  rectangular shape  the base of this rectangle is the radius  of the circle and the height is half of  the circumference because both sides  together make up the circle  since the circumference is 2 pi r half  of it is pi r  the area of a rectangle is its base  times its height  we substitute in the values  and then we multiply to get the area of  the circle as pi r squared  this formula becomes exact when we make  the slices infinitely small  please subscribe to my channel  you can support me on patreon you can  catch me on my blog mind your decisions  on twitter at preschoolwalker and you  can get my books at amazon